today we're going to be speaking with
with ruth ben
giat who is an historian new york
university professor
and expert and uh political commentator
on fascism authoritarian leaders and
propaganda
and it feels like the right time to have
this conversation
uh ruth yeah thanks for having me on
so to start with can you talk i want to
kind of go in order if it's possible
the first where i would like to start is
what are the sort of
conditions in a society that
are the ripest for a strongman type
to grasp control so it was really
eye-opening to me the
the book it goes over 100 years and so i
was looking for
patterns and conditions that recur and
one of them and this will fit
america too in 2016
these these kinds of like strong men
appeal when there's been
a period of great progress social
progress
it could be gender emancipation racial
equity
workers rights and this destabilizes
many people and makes them angry
and so these strong men come up kind of
saying i'm going to turn the clock back
the other condition is polarization and
these leaders do everything they can to
exacerbate that polarization because
they need us to be at each other's
throats
and that helps people to be dependent on
them and it helps them to build their
cults of personality and so in a sense
these are often reactive movements
to prior changes or movements that
that gain steam in society
they are reactive but mussolini uh said
it best he was a journalist he was full
of like good quips
um he said it was a revolution of
reaction because
they also are very charismatic many of
them and they're able to excite people
with the idea that they're promising
something new so trump was very smart to
make it wasn't
just it was a of course with the gop but
it was a movement
and he had the red caps like people want
to be part of a tribe
and so it seemed very exciting to people
and this has been true
of most of these leaders as well one of
the things that's been interesting to me
to see about
the the the movement i guess that we're
now calling trumpism
is i did not identify
anything novel that donald trump was
sort of
pushing on the republican party but he
was
able to sort of just package
the idea of his candidacy as the perfect
place to kind of coalesce ideas that had
been festering in the republican party
for for a long time
do you agree with that and is that
common or or not
you stated perfectly what the what the
process
is every time these these
these men come up and many of them have
um they're very savvy about media and
marketing um
mussolini was a journalist mobutu was a
journalist hitler pride
hitler took voice lessons acting lessons
hypnotism lessons when he was trying to
get to power
so they come up and they were eight
they're able to um
coalesce and channel existing extremist
anti-democratic and other tendencies in
society
and then they form this cult of
personality around themselves and they
give it form and they give it focus
and that's where the movement comes in
and then once they get to power they
legitimize
all of these things and make them into
state policy
i want to zoom out a little bit for
trump but because we're talking about
some of these aspects maybe we'll we'll
stick with it for a moment
um one of the uh revelat so
i've said donald trump did not create
racism or xenophobia but he certainly
was able to sort of coalesce it and
and make a large group of people who had
those ideas feel like they had a home
maybe be a little more comfortable
publicly espousing some of these views
similarly it seems as though donald
trump has also exposed
some of the underlying authoritarian
tendencies
of the american right although they
claim to be very much about small
government and sort of the
libertarian-esque
ideals they were very quick to sort of
look the other way to
trump's authoritarian desires because
they sort of were the type of
authoritarianism that worked for them
is that an accurate assessment in your
mind
absolutely and i think one of the the
strengths that i've had
to approach this is i'm not a i'm not a
specialist in american history
i'm a specialist in global history and
propaganda
and so i came to to started writing
about donald trump and
the gop in 2015 2016. so i train this
kind of global historical lens
on our country it's been very revealing
so one of the things i learned during
research for the book
is that the gop was actually already
moving in this authoritarian direction
so they had already largely given up the
idea of bipartisan governance and the
idea of mutual toleration where
you know you have excuse me
you have an opponent and you maybe
differ
you don't agree with them but you don't
ask for them to be
jailed or locked up so donald trump took
advantage of this
and and since 2016 there have been some
comparative politics studies coming out
and they're really eye-opening that they
place the gop
in the context of like world political
parties the gop
actually lines up for its rhetoric and
its platforms with far-right parties
like modi's party in india and erdogan
and turkey
it doesn't line up with traditional
conservative parties
so so donald trump was a perfect match
for this party and he
almost he it's like he completed its
transformation because he's such an
extreme individual
is it surprising to you in a historical
context how quickly
the early opposition from within the
republican party
fell apart in the sense that if you
think back you know ted cruz was
attacking donald trump during the
primary marco rubio rand paul
fox news was not with donald trump but
very quickly with very few exceptions
you know mitt romney john mccain etc
they all fell in line is that common
historically
this is one of it's so sad i felt so sad
for
america writing this and thinking about
this because
it you know these extremists depend
on uh political leads to bring them in
the system
and this is what the gop did people like
jeff sessions
who in february 2016 introduced trump to
a rally and trump actually said
oh i'm becoming mainstream and i thought
oh my god here it goes
right the sad thing and this applies to
fox news as well as
others is once these um these these
kinds of authoritarian minded rulers
everybody has to be used and discarded
so look what he's done with fox news
which is really like a co-producer of
his presidency
and there are elements in fox news that
are still defending his attempt to
nullify the election results but they've
turned against
fox news and this is typical that these
early enablers often
get thrown away and they're used and
discarded like everybody else who comes
into his orbit
can you talk so now zooming out a little
bit can you talk a little bit about the
typical playbook the typical playbook
and the process
through which these strongmen have
historically come to power you've talked
a little bit about the circumstances
that
are ripe for such a coming to power but
what is the process generally speaking
so the there's this playbook and the
core of the book of these chapters on
their tools of rule propaganda
corruption i added a corruption chapter
um the myth of national greatness
and violence and so once they come to
they can come to power in different ways
and so going over 100 years is really
interesting because
you had fascist takeovers you had
military coups
and now you have this period where they
come to power via elections
and then they manipulate elections to
stay in power
so this is what donald trump has been
trying to do
and it's very sad that over the time i
wrote the book
several of these strong men like have
consolidated their powers so putin
amended the russian constitution
so he can stay there until 2036. and
orban in hungary rules by decree
and these are the people trump admires
so this was
his playbook um from the start
and when you look at when the playbook
uh stops working or when when thing
let me let me rephrase what can change
in a society uh such that
the society starts more strongly
rejecting
the strong man that at some point they
were more welcoming of
so historically it's difficult to get
rid of them
um and in real fascist one-party states
it took
in both italy and germany it took them
getting bombed by the allies
to start kind of fragmenting the
personality cult
um so you need some kind of large
disaster like a national health crisis
i'm it's very um sad but not surprising
to me that donald trump
received more votes in 2016 than in
2020 than 2016 despite criminal
mismanagement of the pandemic
yeah and once they get their hold and
they consolidate their personality cult
it's very difficult for people to um
peel away from it and his achievement is
all the more
um it's it's all the more of a success
because
you know he didn't have total control of
the media and he didn't even have uh he
didn't own
own tv networks like sylvia bellusconi
in italy
so i would never underestimate trump
he's had an enormous success with what
he's done
can you talk a little bit about um the
role that
masculinity and ideas of masculinity
hyper masculinity will will sometimes
play for
these strong men and and specifically
and one of the interesting things about
trump is in many ways he really is not
the image of masculinity i mean
everything from
he figured out a doctor's note to not go
to vietnam
and he's often you know the way if it's
raining or too
hot he regularly complains and cuts
short his rallies and yet
the narrative is still one of trump as
the hyper masculine guy you have
trump supporters who over the last day
or two have been having a field day on
twitter
because this musical artist harry styles
wore
a dress which they find to be the
opposite of masculinity but but yet
they're supporting a guy
who's not really actually the image of
masculinity
does so to what degree does it matter
and how can someone who isn't even that
actually claim to be it so successfully
this is the this is the personality cult
once they bond to him and they believe
in him
he can it's he's like teflon you know a
teflon figure
nothing sticks to him but this was one
of the surprising things in doing the
research about the book
because the masculinity of the strong
man is actually quite complex on the one
hand they pose at the alpha males and
and you know it's more understandable
those who came to power through military
coup
or you know both hitler and mussolini
had served in the military
bolsonaro was in the in the military and
he harks back to military dictatorship
trump's a little different and so his
again his success is all the more
astonishing because he as you said he he
never fought in the military in fact
he's been very
scornful in many ways of the military
but he still has this alpha
male and he knows how to play on that
very well
but the other half of the strongman uh
masculinity
is that as you've noticed they're always
whining they're always the victim
and this is really in contrast to
traditional notions of virility where
you're strong and silent right this
is somebody who can't be quiet via
twitter via again whining whining
and this however works to their
advantage because it makes people feel
protective of him so i've got a lot of
quotes of people who say
i'd walk through a sea of covid to save
donald trump
because he's endangered and this is why
all of them have these victim complexes
and victim cults
and so even though trump is leaving
office
his victimhood cult will be more active
than ever
yes and that will be something we will
have to sort of figure out
how to contend with the book is
strongmen mussolini to the present and
we've been speaking with the book's
author
ruth ben giat a ruth congratulations on
the book and i so appreciate your time
today
thank you for having me on